hey this is prashtal walker reminding
you to mind your decisions
today mit ranks as one of the top
universities in the world
150 years ago this problem appeared on
its entrance exam
reduce the following fraction to its
lowest terms the numerator is x to the
power of 6 plus a squared x cubed y
and the denominator is x to the power of
6
minus a to the fourth y
squared pause the video if you'd like to
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem it helps to know
the difference of squares formula
this states that a squared minus b
squared is equal to the product of a
plus b and a minus b
but if you didn't know this formula how
would you derive it
let's go through a geometric explanation
consider one square with an area of a
squared and a smaller square with an
area of b squared
let's subtract the area of the smaller
square from the larger square
the area that remains is a squared minus
b squared
but we can also solve for the area in
terms of rectangles
consider this rectangle which has one
side of b and another side of a minus b
we also have this rectangle which has
one side of a and another side of a
minus b
both of these rectangles have a side
length of a minus b
so why don't we join these two
rectangles along this side
when we do that we end up with one long
rectangle
one side is a minus b and the other side
will be a plus b
the area of this rectangle is the
product of these lengths and that's the
difference of squares formula
so let's use it to solve this problem
let's focus on the denominator
notice it's actually a difference of
squares
it's the difference of x cubed being
squared and a squared y being squared
we then use the difference of squares
formula on these terms to get the
following
we now simplify the numerator
notice that x cubed is a common factor
to both terms
when we factor this we get the following
we now take the numerator over the
denominator
and both have the term
x to the power of 3 plus a squared y
so these will cancel out
and we're left with the answer of x
cubed all over x cubed minus a squared y
it's a neat little problem and it's fun
to know that problems we solve in math
class today were still important
problems 150 years ago
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you